übrigens ab hiess collecting von rolex einen
guten zweck also ja es sieht zwar aus wie der
verlorenen bruder von patch vor henning heute
geht es aber nicht um aktien wir werden heute
versuchen den amerikanischen traum eines jeden
kindes war zu machen indem wir geld mit einem
lemonade an fakten wie viel das sein wird was wir
verkaufen und was wir alles machen das hier jetzt
viel spaß mit dem video in den filmen wird das
immer glorifiziert die kinder stellen sich auf
die straße verkaufen limonade in abgewandelter
form können wir das in deutschland auch machen
wir können keine offenen getränke verkaufen
wir können nicht das verkaufen würden das nicht
verkaufen aber wir können geschlossener
getränke verkaufen können gerade sondern
kaufen könnt ihr verkaufen wir können cola fanta
sprite die standard sachen können wir verkaufen
als allererstes müssen wir dafür unsere getränke
einkaufen kleine marktanalyse wir können natürlich
jetzt nicht an einem tag so viel erfahrung sammeln
dass wir wissen was verkauft sich am besten was
verkauft sich gar nicht und deswegen fragen wir
bei den leuten nach die ihr geld damit jetzt schon
hatten was ist eigentlich das getränk was sich
am besten verkauft wer hätte es gedacht die gute
alte maate kann man auch relativ teuer verkaufen
also wenn man jetzt in so einem kleinen stand ist
was nimmt man dafür also safe 2 aber vielleicht
sogar 250 also club mate fritz kola capri-sonne
durstlöscher sind die einen alkoholischen getränke
die am besten laufen also kaufen wir genau die
wir sind durch was wir bezahlt haben
wie viel umsatz wie man das schon
jetzt leicht mal wenn wir alles von außen kommen
insgesamt 90 euro und 7 cent ausgegeben
mehrwertsteuer so es gab schon einige kommentare
dazu mehrwertsteuer nicht ganz zusammen gibt es
in diesem projekt nicht wenn wir alles verkauft
bekommen machen wir einen umsatz von das war
richtig geil aber weniger als gedacht wir haben
zwei kästen club mate ein kasten fritz kohler ein
paket wasser und dreimal kap die somit mehr gibt
es dann an unserem level stent nicht und damit
müssen sich dann die leute zufrieden geben hier
sicherte monate verkaufen häufiger in der limonade
verkauft und dann glaube ich nicht mal das angebot
wir stellen einmal demonstrativ alles aus was
wir haben mit so eis so dass sie das bekommen
könnt ihr mit eurem geld überreicht werden wir
vielleicht gibt's ja auch noch leute die das
ganze projekt noch ein bisschen mehr vielleicht
sollten wir so einen spendentopf aufstellen wänden
für rolex ja genauso machen müssen lemonade stand
sie ja nicht los natürlich kommt auch die echte
dpa lhe nach ich drauf das ist kein geld direkt
in meine rolle die es vielleicht doch nicht meine
rolex oder zu mir in den nächsten videos bitte
geben sie mir geld ich brauche eine rolex-uhr
max und da habe ich doch her ich danke geworden
da kann ich ehrlich das ist ja mal besser das
ist ja schon 0 0 0 1 2 prozent der rolex frau
ich bin ehrlich gespannt ob und wie viel geld
oder mit 40 auf ich könnte mir vorstellen dass
es gar nicht funktion oder ist leute das bild
ich bin ja ja genau oder dann einfach mehr geld
in die trinkgeld rolex kasse kommt als investoren
wir sind angekommen hoffentlich ort des glücks
sind am aachener weiher einer der bestbesuchten
parks in köln und wir werden uns direkt an den
eingang stellen also jeder der rhein will jeder
der raus will muss an unserem stand vorbei gehen
wir jetzt direkt hier vorne aufschlagen werden und
dann hoffentlich hoffentlich entweder ein paar
spenden bekommen oder die gesamten getrennt es
fühlt sich ziemlich bald ein bisschen unangenehm
wie sommer ist zu ende und ich mache das jetzt
herzlich willkommen in meinem
ganz eigenen erster lemonade cent
es ist soweit der lemonade steht wir sitzen
seit einer minute und jetzt kann es losgehen
ich hoffe dass hier ein paar leute vorbeikommen
die durstig sind die unsere getränke abnehmen
und dann hoffe ich auf großen umsatz und
noch viel größere spenden mein bedürfnis
steht auf dem spenden ding und ich hoffe die
leute nehmen das wahr und nehmen das ernst
der hammer gut aufgestellt ihr habt schon
dass ein genauer ja unser schild vorne haft
eisgekühlte getränke wenn man dann tatsächlich
nur eis gekühlten da er dann nehme ich nicht
okay aber ich würde euch damit haben wir für euch
allen eine steuer dann gewerbe maßnahmen multi bad
multicar money also ist gut dass sie da sind
damit war ein bisschen zeit zum durchatmen
habe ich sehe daher dr platz ist weiß halt
deine fresse ich glaub da hinten ist das
denken ist alle leute die ohne getränke zum
aachener weiher kommen was ihr sehr viele
machen die müssen alle hier haben mir vorbei ist
es schlauer seine produkte selbst zu konsumieren
ich glaube ich muss erst ein bisschen was
verschenken was machst du gerne haben neben
dem klub neuer du kannst nach eigenem
bemessen etwas in die rolex passt tun
du kannst ja auch wieder etwas rausnehmen
danke ja genauso gut einen cent geben um
fünf monate davon nehmen oder in dem eine
marke für zwei euro dein körper gut gelaunt
vielen dank jungs ja besser kann es nicht
laufen also die leute anzusprechen funktioniert
tatsächlich lässt ganz kurz für mich das
verkaufen übernehmen ich muss kurz telefonieren
marien hat es gibt die nicht nur karten die
doch es gibt auch pate für mich sein wo ich
bin und gesagt was machen sie heute noch was
los wenn die kölner zeit stehen geblieben
hier war es einfach so mitnehmen
doch zwei euro ja die schönsten mädchen die wir
uns nehmen der kleinbus bestätigen durchkommen
die menschen werden reich ist nicht da
wie gesagt ein nagel aber jetzt haben
sollte ein wasser fließen
wenn ihr jetzt keine lust habt könnt ihr auch
nur wenn es galt sich wieder den
greenfreeze collecting von rolex
ich warte noch einmal doch wofür macht
für den euro ländern für den guten zweck
was ist ein guter zweck das ist ja eine
rolex-uhr für mich eine kleine spende
ich kann eine gold creole spenden unsere
echt gold die könnt ihr einfach einen bösen
den fernsehmarkt heute paar verloren darf
ich darauf weist noch doch tatsächlich ich
danke dir mal aber ist winterthur leiter
immer seine caprice gibt es gleich sondern
wirtschaft ist sich 60 80 85 90 7 80 eur 76
verdient ja quasi kein - und das video war
ein voller erfolg wenn ich das video gefallen
hat lassen wir gerne leider vergessen kann als
abonnieren und wir haben außerdem noch
eine goldkette geschenkt bekommen dass
kein witz und die ist wirklich cool wir
sehen uns nächste woche ist macht's gut